أعلن الحوثيون مسؤوليتهم عن
هجوم مزدوج بطائرة بدون طيار
وأكد المسؤولون الإماراتيون أن طائرات بدون طيار أو
نوعًا ما يشبه طائرة بدون طيار
شوهد في الهواء فوق أبو ظبي ،
وكان هناك نوع من
الضربة على مشارف أبو ظبي
الدولية.  مطار بالفعل في المنطقة
التي يبنون فيها مطارًا دوليًا جديدًا في أبو ظبي
،
والأهم من ذلك كان هذا الإضراب في
مرافق تخزين النفط ومنشآت المعالجة في
الجنوب ،
وهو ما أشعل ما نفهمه وفقًا
للمسؤولين الإماراتيين أن خزان وقود يتسبب
في حدوث تفاعل متسلسل  نتج
عن انفجار صهريج وقود يحمل
ربما نفطًا نوعًا من
المنتجات المكررة الانفجار الذي أدى إلى مقتل
ثلاثة أشخاص أه إصابة ستة آخرين في
تصعيد كبير
جدًا والحوثيين قالوا إنهم لم
يسموا بالفعل أه الإمارات
بعبارات مهينة  لدولة صغيرة
كما أطلقوا عليها
ولكنهم يقولون إن هذا البلد
يمكن أن يتوقع المزيد  من هذه الأنواع من
الهجمات وهذا رداً على فهمنا
ربما لإمدادات سرية أو دعم
لحلفاء إماراتيين سابقين في قتالهم المستمر
ضد الحوثيين ،
وقد
عانى الحوثيون من بعض الانتكاسات مؤخرًا
والتي يعزونها جزئيًا إلى
إعادة المشاركة على مستوى معين
من  الإمارات لم يكن لدينا ذلك الذي
تم تأكيده رسميًا بالطبع من
الجانب الإماراتي